I got my first head school when I was 16
it was my mama died right on my neck no
you got to get picked like this the
person who made you won't be building
everyone for hustle
I had to stump up my mom and uh Tim
actually when I got it I got addicted to
tattoo it was up to my first answer
probably like today's week my second one
is almost back up underneath a hug but
it's on the back is the egg honey you
say 800 it's just like my who is like
what we stand for
I had to put it on me too like all my
tattoos is really like you got it got
certain meanings behind
I've been when I got my first face
tattoo like this dog my brother he's
lying sleeping here died his favorite
color rear so I just got it like a rare
bird oh my when I did it is like my
uncle he pulled me to the side I know
you gonna make it around I know you
gonna make it a wrap now you've attached
lose your faith ain't got no other
choice but to be successful I mean I
thought hard on it I thought hard on the
situation with me and I like he just
meant a lot to me so I gotta go and get
its head I gotta go in the room do a lot
probably 2016 2016 my friend
I like the flame I like like to cut the
flames on my neck with the colors in
them
he's crying this got it on both sides
really I really had a little favor
attention but the tension that mean the
most on me is my other brother
Ehlo he's had it on the side of my face
his name yellow and the day he died it's
on the other side right side and I got
hardly it's right here on the top
it's like heartless it was like like
when I came to game off I said I was
saying two things I was saying I was
heartless and I was federal and didn't
that caught me like money bag Meyers so
you know he used the knife and I'll it
it's like like a knife if you get close
and you see you like with the blood
dripping on foot it's like art to those
the name of my projects my albums they
took me to hold on a space in my life so
I had to colleges
put them on
oh I liked a lot of killing gage tattoos
you got real are doing like you know
like faces there's kind of what I want
to do like with my back and my stomach I
want to get like all my kids faces on my
stomach or something like that a lot of
more faces and stores people there being
a lot something like on my back like
probably I might get the Memphis breach
that's something like that on the back
awesome Memphis from I might get the
house I grew up in on my back or
something beat and I'll tell them go
crazy when I was coming up getting
tattoo I really I want to own so who who
live in Sand Island I just want to
tattoo so bad and but it's now I look at
it like it's important your skin is your
buddy
and I just want to work with we over to
like blue the best art we're gonna do
the best awkward right now oh yeah I got
a money back plus some Winnebago so I
got a big money Barry these type of hurt
it a lot too I'm like dope it's like a
big money bag I like bring somebody
coming out the top right flames all
around
you know my Nick like the back of the
Nick and I thought it was the most
painful tension not affectionate heart
like actually I don't even heard like it
close to you hope you hurt I got some
work on my new album time served you
know saying elevation when you hear
elevation hard work dedication on time
so when I meant time served was it's the
last series of the federal when I first
started like I'll telling I told you our
federal no hugs I did series to both
projects and the Harless series I ended
it will fail the hard to tell my last
project but federal is like federal to
federal I deal with got it
better than three times and time serves
like for Virginians like the final but
it's just like going to another level
I'm entering a new space
[Music]